all right guys new day time to start the
no trash challenge i'm happy that i'm
learning about this because
this is just proof that there's a lot
that people still need to be educated on
to save the environment
thank you so much for agreeing to try to
not make trash for
24 hours only percent of plastic
has actually been recycled of all the
plastic
ever created so the whole thing with
zero waste
is essentially being like okay well if
only nine percent of plastic is getting
recycled
maybe we should try to not make it in
the first place i'm really excited to
look at the trash that you made
yesterday so
let's get into it let's go through it
all right so i guess we can start off
with
a big bottle of ginger ale nice
recyclable
we have a container for miso soup paper
bag whitening strips
pepsi can some more boxes for food and
actually slap some food in there
i usually for lunch and dinner get take
out cardboard box for milk
hard bottle of water we got some more
containers here for food
we got another bottle here i have a lot
of napkins obviously i could probably
keep these and use them
these are just leftovers from mcdonald's
bags that i have just this lemon inside
of plastic bag
for my sweet tea you're doing good
you're doing what most americans do we
all make about 4.3 pounds of trash a day
so the tips that i'm going to give you
are to first
try to opt for aluminum and glass over
plastic try to cook at least one of your
meals so instead of getting like an
individual sweet tea a day in a plastic
thing
get a bulk container from the grocery
store it's one
big plastic container still but it's
still better than five individual ones
another tip is when you're ordering your
takeout i'm going to challenge you to
write please no
plastic utensils or napkins
all right sounds good i'm ready let's do
it good luck
so i don't have any ingredients to cook
some breakfast or any lunch dinner
i'm going to have to go to the grocery
store so we're going to head there but
first i'm gonna get some food
get some sushi with my boy eric so i'm
gonna go there and see if i can use the
least amount of plastic
paper anything is possible so let's just
get started a lot of times before i head
out stay hydrated
i'll take a bottle of water but no trash
i know plastic's one of the worst things
so i'm just gonna get a glass of water
from the sink
ah cheers cheers saving the planet now
one drink at a time
just got to the restaurant ordered my
drink i got lemonade
and it actually came in a plastic cup i
asked them they could put in the glasses
so they can't
so i'm just going to not use a straw
save trash that way
i'm not going to use chopsticks so
hopefully they have some utensils that
they have back there
and if they don't i'll just use my hands
but i gotta do what i gotta do
avoid the plastic for the sauce not
gonna use any chopsticks
no straw so one of the challenges was
try not to use plastic utensils when you
get takeout
or you can go in at a restaurant i think
i got that one down so
what's the next one passing some of the
fast food places right now
i usually get nice coffee or sweet tea
but today
i gotta get things in bulk and avoid
getting any plastic
try get glass so i'm gonna try to make
two of those challenges
on this trip right now to the grocery
store let's do it i do have a youtube
video to record today we're doing a
challenge where
last person leave the bathtub with
thumbtacks so i do have to get a lot of
thumbtacks but that doesn't mean it's
trash we could still reuse those things
so
let's start with that first all right
got the stuff for the video out of the
way
can't avoid the trash on this because i
have to buy the thumbtacks but
obviously i'm gonna recycle it so let's
go get the food let's go see if we can
just get stuff in bulk
and just glass containers we should be
good to go i'm gonna try to cook my own
meal tonight
i'm just gonna boil some chicken put
some seasoning on there
and then the only thing that's gonna be
trashing this is the container making
food at home
check for sure i probably need some
honey as well so let's see if they have
some glass containers for that
on the way to honey though we're packing
peanut butter as well sometimes i like
to mix honey peanut butter oats
pretty good so these are plastic
containers it's not gonna work
organic creamy that's gonna work out
glass as well
and then honey we have glass containers
as well
your wildflower last thing they know
both of my favorite drinks are here
sweet tea and i've got iced coffee right
next to it so
just get these in bulk and be good to go
thank camila at home
i think we're doing well so far so let's
do it
[Music]
so i'm not gonna use any plastic bags
either because plastic's the worst thing
i got a package i ordered this probably
like a week ago so once i open it
obviously i'm gonna do what i can to
recycle and do what's right but
zero trash is hard to avoid this one
another way that i'm able to avoid trash
for today i got some tantries
you know so it's just the skin a lot of
times you are going to see me using
paper towels
but i've been trying to avoid that for
no trash by using just a towel
bone for romeo he does not
act and then we have this plastic right
here to recycle
kind of crazy how nine percent you know
nine percent gets recycled like that's
that's crazy all right last thing the
bathroom
so a lot of times you guys see me using
these
floss sticks uh but today just to avoid
trash
24 hours i'm gonna have to not use this
i'm just gonna have to brush my teeth
so how was your day how did it go
honestly i had to change a lot of my
lifestyle but i stuck to the four
challenges that you gave me
and i think i did pretty well some
things were unavoidable for example like
i got
mail i know this was so difficult so
thank you for
even trying and the earth thanks you too
is there anything that you think you
might incorporate moving forward from
this challenge
yeah so definitely not going to order
utensils tell them to avoid those
try to cook it home more often
definitely just going to try to avoid
more and more plastic
when he told me those statistics i was
honestly surprised i didn't know all
that so
we don't need everyone doing zero waste
perfectly
we need everyone doing it imperfectly
zero waste is just one way to help the
environment the biggest way that
we can reduce our impact is by eating
less meat and flying less
i'm just happy to be part of this and
happy to just make the world a
cleaner and better place so thank you oh
thank you so much for being a part of it
and how can we listen to your music and
like find you on youtube
my ep next level is dropping i can't
wait so you can
listen on all stream platforms music
videos gonna drop on the youtube channel
dober brothers as well
maybe there'll be a song about zero
waste in your future who knows
i think we're good guys so i did glass
containers instead of plastic
buying things in bulk making sure not to
ask for utensils
and cooking a meal at home i ate the
tangerine
definitely decreased my trash for the
day so
we're good to go thanks for this
[Music]
[Music]
opportunity
[Music]
you